[Music]
what's fussing to me is it's a big leap
of faith for all of you to take on this
assignment because the director comes to
you and says okay we're gonna shoot this
movie and it's gonna take 12 years so
what's gonna happen is you're gonna I'm
gonna need you what once a year for a
couple of weeks that's a how do you know
I mean that's a big risk that you're all
going to still want to be in acting that
kids are gonna turn up to be adult good
actors that all of you were gonna
survive you know it's crazy I know and
when you think about it like that it
sounds crazy I mean one of the first
times we realized that we were onto
something really unique was when we
realized that we couldn't sign a
contract for it right I mean it's
illegal to do something for more than
seven years contractually right right
right so the whole thing became an act
of faith but no I didn't really worry
about it it's just I mean if I died I
mean I wouldn't be around to worry about
it right I mean so I'm glad chillax is
in the dictionary cuz you're the most
relaxed guy Richard Linklater said to me
said look if I die you have to finish it
so there was a kind of we just hoped for
the best and it worked out beautifully
more to the point the truth is the
really surprising thing statistically is
that the guys who produced the movie you
know who financed it yeah still had
their job most of those guys you know
mostly I mean the guy he had to hide a
couple hundred thousand dollars a year
for over a decade
well we slowly made this movie right
that he didn't get fired for doing such
a thing
yes it's pretty remarkable yeah in this
town for someone to last 12 weeks is it
is a long time there's a lot of
parallels between your character and
yourself for example your character
loves Star Wars and I could tell it felt
like in that scene I know you have you
see them I know they little item well
I've talked to you before and I know
you're a huge Star Wars fanatic and then
there's a part in the movie where your
character is talking to his son about
Star Wars and I could tell you're
channeling your real passion here is
that I think so well what people didn't
know is I was just actively campaigning
to be in the new Star Wars film and I
thought if I talked about it
passionately and I showed my inner Jedi
you
let you know the lucasfilm's raj
whoever's in charge AJ Abrams now yeah
yeah well you know I thought this would
be I knew that I would get to be on your
show yeah and that you would ask me
about it and then I could actively
campaign for a role in the new Star Wars
right now yeah this is the this is the
time to do it now you the character you
want to play you told me one since you
want to be a Wookiee is that right I
think I did say that yeah we have you
know what we actually keep these tapes
no one thinks we do or should but we
keep the tapes and you said you want to
be a Wookiee
does that mean I'm gonna have to
audition it for a whoopin right now go
for it no don't do that did you just put
a put on a carpet and you know walk
around yeah you put on the carpet or gas
yeah I thought you do to be a whoopee
yeah I'm trying to prove to them that I
too can be a wookie yeah you can do it
with me we'd be like a comedy duo it
really it's all stupid wookie yeah the
minute I walked on with my super long
legs whatever and I'd have red hair come
in like people would be like how did
Conan get in this movie and screw it up
you know what's really fun is that
there's a there's a part in the movie
where you that I was watching with my
wife last night and there's a part in
the movie where you're called on to skip
a rock across the pond
and you pick up a rock and you skip it
and it's an amazing throw and an amazing
series of skips and my wife said out
loud that was really good
and we live in an age of CGI the mommies
with AIDS conquering the universe right
and your wife was impressed with the
skipping what I'm saying is you're
hearing
if you say it that I've lowered the bar
for my wife to be impressed by pods
right no wookie for him JJ I been
hearing other people comment well the
funny things is I watched the movie with
my son and at that exact same moment he
tournament that's cool he was he too was
impressed with the skipping rock but uh
I personally feel like one of the things
that makes me so happy about this movie
is it's really celebrating ordinary life
yes
and it's something I really believe in
and it makes me the fact that your wife
would be impressed by that
yes na we're we makes movies were meet
where people are stopping a media or
using a giant laser or robots or coming
out of the sea and her you have this
movie it's about real life and what's
fascinating about it is that there's a
lot of tension building in the movie
here and there but then very real life
treatment of it you don't I mean where
it's not a movie about extraordinary
things happen but you're riveted the
whole time well you just said it better
than I could
you